it exemplifies what my cooking is which
is like not bound to just one cuisine hi
my name is deep Tran and today I'm going
to be making moon ball so I am
Vietnamese my family identify culturally
as northern Vietnamese so my food
reflects that kind of northern
Vietnamese tradition well first thing to
know about lemongrass is you need to
start with fresh lemongrass if you go to
the market and it looks really dry the
oils have dissipated already it was not
aromatic then it's past its prime
because what you're trying to do when
you're making this chili oil is to trap
the oils that are in the lemongrass this
is seared hangar with lemongrass chili
oil it served as a salad with noodles
pickles lettuces herbs peanuts shallots
your typical in a way it combines all
the things that I love and also it's
inspired actually by the tradition of
chimichurri you know the idea that
instead of marinating meats beforehand
you sear it simply and then you add on
aromatics everybody has a different
stove everybody has a different pot so
when I tell people how to judge when
this recipe is ready to move on to the
next step you want to check if the oil
has turned red fish sauce is key to this
dish in various components one being the
lemongrass chili oil it just adds like
this depth of flavor that's very
different than just salt alone it adds a
savoriness to it and you want to use
like a good fish sauce with just like
two ingredients salt and anchovies so
what you're trying to do with the jump
is you're trying to balance salty with
sweet with acid you're mellowing it out
so it becomes like a vinaigrette my
favorite way to sear a steak is actually
to oil the steak instead of the pan
because I like to get the pan super
super hot and then the moment I put in
oil it's just gonna burn so what I'd
like to do is I put it onto the steak
itself massage it in there
it's properly oiled so that it won't
stick to the pan but it won't burn I cut
this hanger like on the rear side of
medium rare and almost like just just
searing really you can go medium if you
like the next jump is a vinaigrette
essentially so it will kind of cure
meats too so if you want it a little
higher in temp
you can kind of mimic that but just you
know marinating the sauce for like
thirty minutes you'll get the texture
that I'm going for but the doneness that
you want I like this dish to have a lot
of birds because for lack of a better
word like it just pings you know like
it's not OneNote it's not just herb it's
two kinds of herbs it's not just the
crunch of peanuts it's the punch of
peanuts plus the crunch of shallots it
works in concert this recipe for a
lemongrass chili oil is a bigger recipe
than you'll need but why not make a
bigger batch you can serve this on rice
you can serve this with eggs just put it
in your refrigerator lasts about three
weeks if not more I just definitely like
to be my own world didn't really
identify with the aspirations of my
cousin's identify is clear in the sense
that not beholdin to any tradition yeah
you know not cared as much for the
status quo you know I asked this a lot
by actually other young Vietnamese
queries it kind of like really have a
lot honest about it I said you like your
parents do what your parents do do you
know like in the end you live your own
life you know and I feel like you answer
to yourself we don't have to do anything
like the previous generation we can
queer it up if I couldn't give advice to
young queers particularly Asian Pacific
American queers I would say don't worry
about what other people expect you to be
oh yes
[Music]
you